أعلن رجال الأعمال اللبنانيون
أنهم لن يدفعوا الضرائب
بعد ما يقرب من شهرين من الاحتجاجات الجماهيرية
على الفساد الرسمي
وعدم الكفاءة ، حيث يمر القطاع الخاص
بأزمة عميقة حيث بدأ الاقتصاد اللبناني
في الانهيار في
الشهرين الماضيين  العملة
فقد الزعيم ثلث قيمتها ، وفي
الأسبوع الماضي ، تلقى وزير العمل المؤقت
طلبات من 60 شركة
لفصل مؤيديهم بالكامل من
الإضراب الضريبي ويقولون إنهم لا يستطيعون القيام
بأعمالهم كالمعتاد.
قادرين على دفع
رواتب لأشياءي غير المؤكدة التي
تقتل هذا البلد ، فنحن لا نعرف
ما الذي تديره عائلة منهج شل القادمة
سلسلة من متاجر السلع الرياضية مع
البنوك التي تقيد بشدة الوصول إلى
الدولارات التي تستورد السلع التي نتركها جميعًا
انضم حديثًا إلى الموظفين
الذين كانوا  القوائم المنضمة لمدة
تقل عن ثلاثة أشهر ، نسمح
لهم جميعًا بالذهاب إلى عدد من 25 إلى 30 بالإضافة
إلى ذلك اضطررنا إلى إنقاص 25  النسبة المئوية
للرواتب لكل فرد في الشركة بدءًا من
الرئيس التنفيذي لدينا وإلى أسفل التسلسل الهرمي ، فإن الأمر
لا يمثل أزمة بقدر ما هو انهيار إذا
واصلنا تجاهل المشكلة والبقاء
في حالة إنكار ، فهذا يعني أننا
سنستنفذ الأشياء الأساسية للمحلل المالي
دان  يقول Ozzie إن لبنان بحاجة إلى تعلم
العيش في حدود إمكانياته ، فهو
يستورد حاليًا كل شيء تقريبًا من الطعام
والأدوية إلى العناصر الراقية وينتج
القليل جدًا من الأشياء التي
اقترحتها هي لعبة كبيرة على أشياء
مثل سيارات v8 v6 ، أعني إذا ذهبت  إلى
باريس ، لا ترى رينج روفرز كما
تراه في لبنان ، فأنت لا تراها في
لندن كما هو الحال هنا ، لذا إذا
قللنا من سيارات v6 v8 بجعلها
باهظة الثمن ،
فلدينا 350.000 مساعد منزلي
في منطقتنا  منازلنا ، أعني أنك تعرف
كيف نبدأ في إعداد طبقنا الخاص
، وقد بدأ البعض بالفعل في المغادرة
في سفارة الفلبين في بيروت ،
حيث يتقدم المئات من عاملات المنازل
للحصول على رحلات جوية ممولة من الحكومة ، فإن
أرباب العمل الآن يعانون فقط من الألم
وانخفاض قيمة الرصاص  لن يتمكن هؤلاء العمال من
توصيل عائلاتهم إلى منازلهم
دون أن يتكبدوا خسارة كبيرة ، فأنا
الآن أشعر وكأنني شخص واحد ، وهو ما كنت أذهب إليه من
قبل بسبب مشاكل البنوك ،
سيكون شتاء لبنان السخط
عاصفًا على شبكة سي إن إن.